Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah, just checking in on you. I get
bogged down in the mud on that one.
I didn't think I was going to
pull myself up, but you know what?
I reached down deep. Showed
what? I had it on me in on me.
She'll write head in
me. Um, anyways. Yeah.
You know what?
It's nice to be here.
It's nice to be back out here in sunny
la after, uh, going back to New York.
It was chilly fall Billy back there in
the New York City getting soft out here.
And you know what? I love
it. I fucking love it.
That's a big thing that east coast people
are we saying when you go out west,
hey, don't, don't lose
your edge, Bro. Don't,
don't be getting all Hollywood
on the dove like dope.
Okay.
Um, you basically telling
me don't become happy.
That's what you saying dope.
Dope. And get to happy.
What are you going to go do it?
You're gonna walk around.
You're going to get some sandals.
Really?
You fucking toes hanging out or whatever.
Do where some fucking clam diggers.
MMM,
no, it's just nice. I went
back there and I, uh, you know,
I'm one of these fucking La people now.
I don't really have a winter coat coat.
I have a pea coat. Um, it was funny.
This one was breaking my balls.
Tell me it wasn't a real one because I
didn't get it at the army navy store.
It's like those fucking things
that's like wearing thick pajamas.
Pico doesn't work the second it's
below like, you know, 40 degrees.
It's one of those myths that, you know
what, it's got a mid range jumper.
That's what, that's all that fucking code
has. You know what I mean? It can't run.
The court doesn't play any fucking day.
It's too fucking hot.
You know, once you get to like 58 degrees,
it's too fucking hot to wear that coat.
Way Too hot.
55 write that code basically exists from
about 39 degrees to maybe 51 you know
what I mean? If you get a
decent one, forget a decent one.
Like I bought a diesel.
Actually Nia bought me a decent one,
but she used my money to do it. So you
know what I mean? Technically, I mean,
you know, she fucking use my money
so I guess I bought it. You know,
I guess I do have an assistant.
It's my wife
who has access to all my funds.
You got to do that with your wife,
you know what I mean?
Just give her access to all your funds.
It just gives you so much
leverage in an argument.
Just use that next time, you know?
But the sheer ube you a to a,
you were snoring. Just honey, honey,
you have access to all of my funds.
Do you understand that you
have access to all my funds.
I go to an airport in leave, leave you
with access to. I don't. I don't want,
I don't even know what I'm
going to come back to it.
Was there even going to be anything here
now?
What is the problem with the fucking
glass that I didn't wash that always make
me out? Like she's a Nag.
She really isn't. She really
isn't, but it's just, um,
yeah,
I guess it's just a fear of, of, you
know, being with somebody that can,
they can take you for everything.
You've got prenup doesn't mean shit out
here in California. You know what I mean?
You don't have a prenup is in California.
That's like when there's a blitz in
the fullback, misses the assignment.
That's what the Prenup is. You think
that fucker's going to pick up that,
that fucking Lawrence Taylor wanted to
be coming right around the outside. Ah,
he must, he's sitting there
with happy feet. Where is he?
He's buying you and then you get the
old right there, Fred. Right. Well,
you're fucking Bacchae your helmet.
It's the middle of your spine.
As you head snaps back. That's what
a fucking prenup is out here. So,
um, anyways, I don't even want,
I'm talking about here. Um,
I just get back from New York City.
I had such a fucking great time going
back there doing the fifth annual Patrice
O'Neal benefit right out of the gate.
Thank you to everyone that
came down to this show.
The show was unbelievable.
I mean,
I wasn't there last year because
of the snow I got snowed in.
But of the four that I've seen that
might have been the strongest show that
we've had,
we've always had strong shows.
But there was something about that
show was like the perfect level of, um,
of his friends of new guys that were
influenced by him and just the ball break.
And that was going on during the
fucking show. Uh, Jesus Christ,
Rich Vos making fun of
Keith Robinson fucking
what's his face? I think Norton of
course, no one had the best line.
He was talking about how funny Keith was.
He goes,
you should have had a stroke 15 years ago.
I don't understand how Keith had
his stroke and he still talks.
He still eat well,
easier to understand than rich vos.
Those are probably two of the best ones
in Voss. Had like this stupid fucking,
he had like this Paisley shirt from
like the early nineties like every drum
instructional video that I bought from
the early nineties where they didn't have
those jazz guys who are such
good musicians, you know,
you get so good that your music sucks.
After a while they were playing like that.
I'm 94 seven the way,
hey,
that's smooth jazz shit.
You know he had one of those shirts
and then he had like a fucking Justin
Timberlake does fucking bing Crosby,
one of those fucking hipster hats that
even hipsters stop wearing those things
like 10 years ago and it was blue on blue.
So we were backstage,
you know,
all of us fucking jaded
people are gone now. Rich,
it looks good now you should wear
it because he wasn't sure about it.
And Pete Davidson, the new kid, right?
New Kid. He's already on fucking SNL.
It's how old I am. He's, he was
actually telling rich going, you rich,
you can't wear that. It looks terrible.
And I was fine. Like page shut up.
The whole game is that we know it looks.
Don't tell him that.
And he just started laughing.
Then he went along with it and I believe
he took it off his head at the end,
at the end of his set. We had such a
great time and everybody fucking killed,
um,
right out of the gate.
We had Dan soda went up
first after Voss and,
um, he went up there and absolutely
just fucking murdered. It was like he,
he'd been doing it in
theaters his whole life.
Keith Killed Pete Davidson destroyed,
even though he did this whole bit
about there's no excuse to go bald.
That kind of bugged me,
um, in this day and age
saying there was enough medicine
out there with something like that.
Then Jim Norton crushed.
Then it was David Tell
and then Leslie Jones.
And um,
then,
then I had to mop up in the end after
all those guys fucking killing man.
It was awesome. And thank you.
Of course, to Maureen Taren,
who's the real force behind the whole
thing. She puts the whole thing together.
She gets all as a d d comic somehow to
show up at the same place at the right
time every year.
MMM.
She deals with all the finances of,
of renting out the place.
She deals with the whole fucking thing.
I'm so special thanks to her and let,
once again, everybody that came out,
everybody at the stand, you know,
Dave and Chris down at the stand for
always hooking us up with the after party
and all that shit. I'm just had a great
fucking time and that's it. All right.
Um,
until we do it again next year.
MMM.
It really is my phone.
I gotta be honest.
It's my favorite fucking Gig of the year.
It's so much fucking fun cause I get
none of these guys ever get to work with
them now because they all headline
now if I get to see him again,
it's just such a fucking great time.
Jim Florentine just came down to hang out.
I'm trying to make sure I remember
everybody, but it was, uh, it was great.
And I was in New York for
a couple of days and um,
had a great time. Like the
first night, Monday night,
I just went out and I started hitting
all these clubs that I used to. Uh,
you know, I used to work out in, back
in the day when I lived in New York,
I went to Caroline's first.
Okay.
And uh, jumped on this
show and um, you know,
I was waiting to go on and as always,
you know,
he was always end up seeing somebody
funny comedian Carmen Lynch,
who I've seen a bunch of times before,
but I hadn't seen her in awhile.
I'm not going to tell you the bit,
but she did some bit that
was fucking hilarious.
And I believe she's going to be on
Stephen Colbert this Friday night and she
told me she was going to be doing the
bit, the bit's basically about, um,
people that can sleep through
anything. Um, so anyways,
I went up and I have,
I just go on stage and I do the shit
that I'm working on and some older shit
that I'm bringing back.
Then I'm putting a new spin on and it was
just wire to wire this perfect fucking
set. I was taping it. You know,
I have a 0.2% chance that we'll
actually go back and listen to it.
But the fact that I'm recording
it makes me feel good. Right.
And I was actually going to listen to
it because I got these gigs coming up in
Phoenix.
Right.
I gotta get my shit together and this
set ends and for whatever fucking reason,
I never touched the phone. It just shut
off after like two minutes. I'm like,
he gotta be fucking kidding me.
So then I go up to the car,
but I still felt great, you know?
And um, I was like, oh, I remember,
I remember the shit. So I
got to the comic Strip, um,
which was my home club when
I first got to New York,
way back in the day with Lucian,
the late Great Lucian Holt,
we would sit there and go sit there.
You'd walk in and be like, hey yo,
Aleutian neoma but comedian,
I just moved down from Boston.
Yeah.
I already have enough white guys.
He would literally say that
I already have enough void guys.
And I remember all these white guy comics
would get so fucking mad. It'd be like,
you see, you see, it's the
same thing. There's fucking
reverse facing me. It's like,
no, it isn't. It isn't.
You know what the fuck he's saying he
has a million of you and if you're just
going to be another fucking white guy
that grew up in a fucking Culdesac,
he already has it. It's like it's a
grocery store. All right? And he's got,
he's got fucking ears of corn
stacked up to the fucking, you know,
sailing and you come and you want
to buy a Bushel. Now I don't,
you got eat chickpeas.
They're freckles. Right.
So I knew what he meant when he said it.
It's like,
don't come in here and just be doing
the, uh, what's the deal with shit.
So I remember what he said that to me,
I just was a little frustrated,
but I just said to myself, I'll get in
here. I'll get in here eventually. But um,
oh man,
I remember there's so many fucking white
dude comics would get so mad at that.
Um, you could never say that to another
fucking group of people. It's like, yeah,
but it's white on white so he can get
away with it. You know what I mean?
Like black people can say fucked
up shit to each other. It's,
he can keep it in house.
It's like your family.
You can say whatever the fuck you want.
You're still going to sit down
for Thanksgiving together.
You have to your family. You know what
I mean? It's the same fucking thing.
I remember exactly where I was.
I just remember him smiling and nodding
and he closed his eyes and I was like,
oh my God, this guy is actually
an open person. You know,
I'd love to get a spot here and he's
smiling, nodding. I'm like, here comes,
maybe he's going to give
me a phone number of seven.
I already have an old white guys.
I was sitting there with my
stupid backpack just walking away.
We used to always use the reference
of bill Bixby at the end of the hulk.
You know, when he would just be walking
down the road. That sad piano music.
That's how I left the club. But, um,
I had my little positive fucking things
that I would say to myself to, uh,
to get me to, you know, to
go over to the next club.
Who the fuck was over at stand up York
back in the day. He was a good dude.
I remember he had a dead tooth,
that's all I remember. And I would,
I would go in there
and,
um,
he didn't sugarcoat it. It
off. When I walked up to him,
I remember telling him that I was a new
comic and the look of fucking pain on
his see,
just sort of looked up like I was talking
to the side of his head and he just
looked up and he just made this,
this face,
literally like he had a major
operation then they were,
this is the first time they
were removing the bandages.
That was the look on his
face when I talked to him.
I think I actually petered out
through the sentence as like, Hey, uh,
what was the name of, hey, so and so,
uh, my name is Bill Berber community,
just moved down from New York
and I just want to, yeah.
And then I just fucking walked away.
So
all these years later to still be able
to go back to New York and walk into
these clubs and they still know who I
am and they'll actually put me on stage.
The thrill of that and the privilege
of that is never fucking gone away.
So anyways, so I go to, I
go to, uh, the comic strip,
you know, and now I'm feeling
all cocky because I just
had a great set. So, I mean,
all the years that I've done this,
I never see the bomb coming after that.
You know, I'm feeling all fucking good
about myself. I'm like, I'm gonna go up.
We're going to do it.
Just like I did it at Caroline's,
it's going to come out perfectly.
It's going to be fucking, you know,
minted into my brain and this is going
to be a nice cornerstone to start this
next fucking hour. Right. And of course,
I go in there, nobody's paying attention,
small crowds, somebody ordering and,
and, and I don't know what was going on.
It was this giant group of people right
in the front. And they, I think they just,
I basically deduced that they all just
had the ideal childhood and they couldn't
relate to anything I was saying.
And I basically had to start over
after every single joke. And of course,
that was the, the show. One of my
friends came out to see me and, um,
I didn't bomb, but it was like, I
just, it was, you know, you know,
those days weren't just, nothing's
going right. That's like what it was,
except it was in 15 minutes
set. You know, I tell a joke,
it would work and then I try to build on
that momentum and then someone would be
ordering really loud and then I'd
have to stop and then it start over.
It was just a, it was just one
thing after fucking nother.
So it's like Jesus Christ.
So then I get in a cab,
and this is a great thing about New York.
You can do like a zillion spots jumped
in a cab and I went down to the New New
York comedy club.
MMM.
It used to be run by Al Martin and
they redid the whole fucking thing.
And,
um,
that was a place that I did not have any
good memories of for the first fucking
three years that I went there.
Not Three years, but that,
that place of all the places I went to
his heart as the Boston Comedy Club,
the new comedy club was the one that made
me contemplate packing up my shit and
going home.
That fucking place was the land of
the misfit toys fucking comedians.
And that was one of those comedy clubs
where you walked in and there was like a
hundred headshots on the wall and none
of not one picture was of anybody that
made it.
I just remember thinking shit like that.
The punchline in Atlanta used to be
like that Jamie Bendel runs it right.
I used to say Jamie,
for the love of fucking God,
at least near when you walk on the stage,
can you have some head shots here of
people that actually were successful?
Yeah,
they had like the head shot
of every fucking comedian,
whoever tried to fucking make it and
they left it up on the wall. I mean,
some of them came, turned out to
be big time writers and producers,
but you don't know that.
You only know the performers.
MMM.
So the New York Comedy Club was like
that times like fucking 30. And um,
oh my God, did I have some brutal
fucking sets in their brutal sets?
That's the first place I saw Mike Machete.
Um,
Oh man, that, that place. But anyway, so
they did a whole facelift on that place.
And like it was funny,
like psychologically I went back
to where I was when I first, um,
was coming down in New York and I went
in and I sort of recognize the place.
It was still sorta the same floor
plan and uh, it was a great club.
They had, it was the lobby
had happy, hopeful colors,
painted on the walls and shit.
And I went up and ended up
having a great set there. Um,
and then after that I went over to
the stand and then after that I, I,
I met up with Verdesian Derosa and
some other people we hung out. And, uh,
it was just, it was perfect. It
was just like, I remember this,
this is what fucking living in New
York was aside from me being chilly.
MMM.
It was perfect.
And then early in the day I found a
place where I could play drums at some
rehearsal spot.
So it was like,
it was like the perfect fucking
day and then like an Asshole,
I stayed out til like three,
three 30 in the fucking
morning drinking like an idiot,
like a fucking idiot.
Woke up the next day.
I felt like shit I didn't eat for
like the first 12 hours of the day.
And then what do I have to start?
I have a fucking burger and fries.
I was trying to go my whole time not
getting a slice of pizza in New York cause
I always do that because all the
pizza out here fucking sucks.
Even the shit that's good sucks
compared to a pizza on the east coast.
And I finally gave in after the Patrice
benefit and went to this place right
next to the stand and I was like,
I'm just going to get one slice.
And then I walked in, I was like,
oh, that one looks good too.
And then I got to burn the shit out
of the fucking roof of my mouth.
I remember sitting there just going
like, Bill, just let him cool off.
Just let him off. I'm like, well maybe
I'll just, maybe we'll just take a little,
you know when you try to go in like,
you know you'd ever see like the runt of
the litter trying to nurse off the mom
just kind of, kind of, kind of
going on. I was going in like that,
I just still burn the shit out of my
mouth and kept fucking shoving it down my
pie hole. So anyways, I could not
have had a better fucking time.
And um,
yeah,
I gotta tell you man that,
that Patrice benefit,
like we definitely have
our work cut out for us.
MMM.
For next year.
We already have a couple of people in
mind that we're going to try to get to it,
um, to get on the show next year.
So there you go. So that said,
can you tell him typing in my password?
Cause the whole fuck,
I just start talking like half a mile an
hour. And of course I didn't type it in.
Right on. Sorry.
The Mike sliding down my chest here. There
we go. All right, let's move on here.
Um,
let me see here.
Oh, for God's sakes, I already lost. I
was going to try to hide my youtube page.
I don't even know where the fucking
link is anymore. Um, all right.
Can I read a little bit
of advertising here?
Now that we're halfway through and after
the advertising, I'm going to tell you,
I called in a certain person's,
um, radio. Should it die today?
Radio show today or should a radio show
today I called in coach k and Dave syms
basketball and beyond show that's
going to be airing tonight.
MMM.
February 23rd at 6:00 PM
on a Sirius XM channel 84.
Uh,
the Sirius Xm college channel.
MMM.
But you know what's funny,
I can't even fucking listen to it because
I was driving my Jaguar Jackie as I
call it, drives my wife
nuts. The Beautiful Jackie
driving her down the street.
I did a spot at the store.
This is before I went to New York.
It's been raining like crazy out here and
I was driving turned down Laci and ago.
Yeah.
And I'm cruising along and
then I just hit him. Boom.
Out of nowhere it felt like I drove
over something metal and immediately the
dashboard lights up,
check air pressure in the car and at the
front right tire and ended up pulling
into the gas station down there. And I
had a blown out the front fucking tire.
I swear to God my Prius could
have taken that hit, you know.
But now I got the fucking sexy tires on
the fucking Jaguar. Oh my God. Adversity,
right?
Totally just fucking implodes.
MMM.
So then I was like, alright, you know,
I had the locking lugs on it and shit
and I'm like off fuck did did please tell
me I got that thing in the glove box,
which I did. I called AAA, you know,
I got the spare out and everything and
I was looking at the Jack and all that
type of shit. And it
just, I was too afraid to,
things I paid for AAA, so I'm going
to have someone change a tire. Um,
okay.
And then secondly, I was too afraid to
because the car is low to the ground.
I didn't want to stick it underneath the
fucking car and God forbid if I fucking
miss the a frame, you know,
which I did a long time ago.
Granted I was absolutely shit faced
as with a friend of mine was the 80s,
you know, we were drinking and
driving and um, broad daylight.
He gets a fucking flat and I went to
Jack it up and I put the Jack underneath
basically the floorboards and
just put it right through the car.
Um, so anyways, they ended up
changing the tire and everything.
So I had that awful spare tire
and now my car is getting fixed.
I took it over there cause I want to
make sure I didn't fuck up to spit
suspension because I ran over the
crater with my back right tire too. So,
um, long story short,
I came home that night.
My wife fucking gave me the little
emasculating shot. She's like,
I can't believe you didn't do it yourself.
And I was like, oh, well, you know,
I mean, I mean I could if I wanted to. I
mean, I have, you know, I just, you know,
I got AAA. So I mean, you know,
back in the day I used to, uh,
I used to change tires. You know,
I, I'll never forget this day,
started telling this story about how I
change the tire on my fucking Ford Ranger
on the driver's side,
on the side of route one 28 at three in
the morning and how I fucking jacked it
up and I forgot to loosen the lug.
So I had to bring it back down
again to take it off. And, uh,
and I realized the entire time I was
telling her that it was because I was
embarrassed that I felt like
she questioned my man who, like,
I was some pussy that I called Aaa. But
I do have to tell you this, I actually,
um, even if I knew exactly
what the fuck I was doing,
all I had was that little
right angle fucking, you know,
thing to take the lugs off.
And I just assumed that they had
overtalked the fucking thing.
And then there was no way I was going
to get that off unless they had another
piece of pipe to get the leverage,
which is what I learned back in the day
with the old lady three Ford Ranger.
But the guy showed up, he goes, no, he
goes, they tighten these by hand now,
or at least to do a Jaguar.
And he just took it off like butter.
And I was just like, oh Jesus,
maybe I could've done this.
So now I'm obsessed with the fucking weird
as Jack that's in the trunk of my car.
I should probably know how to do
that. You know? Hey, you know what?
Maybe my wife was right. Maybe I am
a pussy. I Dunno. Let's fucking, uh,
you can't change your own tie. Your
fucking Mary. All right. All right.
Black Tux. Everybody looking great
for a wedding. You know what,
Ryan Gosling does not shop here.
Is that him? Was He that he,
he's the guy in the fucking that
great movie, the musical La La Story.
One of the fuck is called. You wore the
white Tux, right? He went, Roger Moore,
black Tux.
Everybody looking great for a wedding
or a special event has never been easier
with blue,
the black tux.com with high quality
rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to your
doorstep. The Black Tux is giving
guys a new way to rent and get this.
The black Tux offers free home.
Try so you can see the fit and feel the
quality of your suits months before the
your event. The best part,
it's completely done online.
No trips to the tuck shop required.
The blacks tux.com lets you create your
look or choose from tons of stylistic
selected outfits starting at just $95
these suits have a modern fit now,
like that old school fit where he just
slung it over your shoulder would get
junk hanging out.
This is a modern fit and are
made from fine Italian wool,
edgy,
the highest quality on the rental market,
and if you have any questions or issues,
their expert customer care team has
your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14
days before your event provided you give
them that amount of time.
Unless you're a shithead like me
and you get it two days before,
that's a full two weeks to try it
on and make sure everything fits.
If anything else is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a
free replacement right away.
When your event's over, just drop your
rental back in the mail. It's that easy.
By the way, if you get it two weeks
before, you better watch what you eat.
Don't start eating
pasta and all that shit.
You're going to pop you fucking Kumba.
Bug Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that call to action?
To get $20 off your purchase,
visit the Black tux.com/burr that's the
black tux.com/burger for $20 off your
purchase at all. Right? What
do we got next? We've got lift.
You know about left,
right?
It's the APP that gets you a
riding two minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Please include all of the following
points during your read. Well,
of course I'm going to you
fucking put them here. I can
say saint, don't skip any.
Um, if you tried Lyft, you
know what I mean? With Lyft,
you can just download the APP request to
drive driver and they show up in three
and a half minutes. On
average. That's really fast.
He just fucking said two minutes.
They have to get you right. Oh,
he said in minutes.
Not two minutes. Sorry.
My apologies to everybody had lift.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through that 10 point safety standard,
including criminal in
DMV background checks.
You'll know you'll get around
quickly and safely, safely,
unlike at that other one
that rhymes with boober.
They don't give a shit as long as you have
a face and a fucking car. Right? Well,
you need hands and feet basically that
if you have the basics of being a human
being, they don't give a shit
stand there with a bloody ax.
When he got a hatchback, right. Lift
drivers are rated after every ride.
It's the only the best stick around.
That's hilarious.
I just picture people getting cut in
August before the football season.
I'm sorry man. I'm sure. I'm
sure you'll catch up. You'll
catch on over at Uber. Uh,
you don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude
with Lyft. You can tip in the APP, which
is obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect
five star rating from the passengers.
It's just a better all around experience.
Plus there's a lot of people that
are just too mean to not do that.
You know what I mean?
I think four is more legit than a five.
You know what I mean? Five is just like,
hey, you know what I mean? You got me,
they're good for you. A I'll
do you a solid, give you a
five. You know what I mean?
Five would you get a
fucking hand job there?
He must have hit the bucket seats right?
Um,
it can reach back and give you a
little fucking a little helper.
What's with you tonight?
You're so relaxed. I'll tell
you I'm loving left. Um,
bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing
in the highest rating. One,
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift.
You got an easy way to avoid drunk
driving. You never have to bum a ride.
You never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting
ride a ride, getting rid of their car,
sorry.
And relying on Lyft to get around.
Are a lot of people doing that?
What exactly is that number of percentage?
That's a word I use in a fucking
argument. Who said that? A lot of people,
and you know what? I don't
blame them evidently. Uh,
right now Lyft is offering our listeners
a special deal. Get three free rides,
up to $10 each. That's up to a $30 value
when you enter my Promo Code Bill Burr.
Just download the free Lyft APP and
enter Promo Code Bill Burr in the payment
section.
You'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each sets up to a $30 value.
If you can't do basic math,
that's Promo Code Bill Burr.
Enter Promo Code Belper.
By the way, you know,
in the middle of that,
I know I did suggest a man reaching back,
giving another man a hand job.
That's not a gay act when
you're paying for a ride, okay?
If that's just a friend of yours,
even if you were in the backseat,
that would be a homosexual act.
But this, you know, look it up.
If you look it up on a taxi drive
back slash hand jobs.com you'll,
you'll see that I'm actually
telling the truth. All right,
what are we getting next here?
What do we got next? Uh Oh wait,
I found my youtube channel.
Beautiful. Okay. Blue Apron.
Everybody. I, you're hungry.
You want to fill up your fucking pie
hole or you got to go to blue apron.
Blue Apron. Talk about how good it
feels to cook for yourself. I love it.
Oh, I love cooking for myself.
I feel it down in my loins.
Every time I pour myself a bowl of
great nuts or corn checks are we checks.
I'm a big fan.
I'm a big fan of the check cereal.
Doesn't it mean it feels good
that you made yourself something?
It feels better to cook for somebody
else, right? Then you get the praise.
Oh my God,
you made it immediate for me.
You know, my dad walked out on me when he
was trying to make me supper one night.
I'll never forget it.
This means so much.
Not all ingredients are created equal,
fresh,
high quality ingredients
make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Talk about your personal experience
with Blue Apron, the meal you cooked,
the ingredients overall, how it tasted,
how it felt, cooking it, et cetera.
This is my bed. In my experience.
They sent me a fucking card,
the $30 fucking worth of free
food or wherever the fuck it is,
and I haven't used it yet. So that's been
my experience, but I'm going to try it.
I'm going, that's a threat. I'm
going to try it and when I try it on,
I'm going to tell you
guys about my experience.
Want to talk to you about the white
apron that they put it on when I cook the
Blue Apron, you know, and
right day you have blue and
then my pubes are red, right?
Red, white, and blue. That's America
right there. He wants some lentil soup.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each
week, each week, each week, each week,
or let blue aprons culinary
team surprise you. Hey, big boy.
What do you do? Oh,
I'm on a culinary team.
Is that rugby recipes are not repeated
within a year, so you'll never get bored.
What if you like a meal? Can you
fucking order it again? That got away.
It's like Haley's comet,
but with food and it's every year.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose for what fits your
needs and there's no weekly commitment
so you don't get deliveries when you want
them to only get deliveries
when you want them. Hey,
what if you're just a fat fuck
and you contend with that?
Can you just order like a different
Sunday every night they tell you,
you know you're fat. We need a
Sunday on a Monday, you know, sorry.
Each meal comes with a step,
a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less. This is like when your
parents help you with your homework.
The next day he got the star on your
forehead and you felt a little queasy.
You know, like I didn't really earn
it. Did I? Blue aprons, freshness.
Guaranteed promises that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right. I liked that.
That's very vague. They'll make it right.
They send a fucking Hooker rover.
Check out this week's menu.
Get your first three meals for free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron.com/ [inaudible] you will love
how good it feels and tastes to create
incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook.
All right, and lastly, but
not leastly. Here we go.
Simply Thay earlier this month,
ces,
the consumer's electronic show wrapped
up ces is this incredible trade show.
The fuck are we talking about
here? Okay, so this is placed,
this is trade show called consumer
electronic show show and evidently it's an
incredible trade show.
All the big tech companies unveiled
their newest innovations. Oh my God.
Can you imagine the fucking
nerds at that thing?
It's like seeing the future
in front of your eyes.
The ends. Yes. Seeing the
future while smelling blue balls
are sponsors.
Simply safe.
Home security was there and they had
one of the most talked about products on
the show.
The new simply safe security camera early,
like the sound of this bump,
bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
The camera connects to the
sensors in your alarm system.
[inaudible].
If an intruder tries to break in, the
camera will automatically start recording.
They're not only will simply save,
call the police band Ben Anelle,
you'll tab the actual evidence
due to do Dododo when it,
so when the police arrived, you can say,
here's the guy. It's truly incredible.
Here's the guy. He'd be that one with the
gun to my head. I got it all on video.
Not this part. The part where he walked
in a plus with simply safe. You can check,
you can check in at home
anytime, anywhere. I like that.
Just live stream HD footage
directly to your smartphone.
If you want to see yourself,
you want to see for yourself what's
simply safe's brilliant technology can do
for your home.
Go to simply safe per.com today.
You'll leave and get a special
10% discount. That's simply safe.
burg.com for 10% off your
home security subsystem.
Simply Safe bird.com oh shit.
I just thought of a good scene in a
fucking movie that I'm never gonna write.
All right,
so you get the fucking simply safe system,
Findlay faith system,
and you're on the road and you check in
to your fucking home to see what's going
on. And not only do you see somebody's
sneaking up to walk the walk to break into
it, it's actually you and
you like, what the fuck?
How can I be there breaking into my shit?
Why would I not be me,
but be someone else stealing my own shit.
And then you realize it's
the robot version of view.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp bomp right.
You could sell that to Tom Cruise
as he was walking to his jet
does yelling through the chain link fence
job.
Simply say you're,
well you see yourself breaking it to
your own house cause you're a robot.
And he would just stop halfway up the
fucking stairs and he'd look over his
shoulder like Bruce Lee and fucking,
I'm sorry, Bruce Willis in diehard.
And he'd be like, he'd be like, what did
you say? I said the, it's a fucking robot,
but it's you.
So you play both of them.
So there's a chance you
could win a fucking Oscar.
All right? Then he'd be right up
fucking against the chain link fence,
right his nose poking through one of
the holes and you've got to hand him the
script and then he'd be like, I'm sorry
you gotta go through the proper channels.
It's just the way it works.
Okay,
so now you're on your way
over to Scientology won't
go and Cook Donk Donk. Donk.
Donk, donk, donk, donk. Right. You
fucking Paul and Dave tether too. Right?
Show me with the fucking big smile,
but just a weird look in their ride.
Greet you.
Yeah.
They're like Mr. Cruz said you were going
to come over with your fucking robot
movie about him. I'd be
like, yeah, yeah it was.
And they big w would you like some tea?
And I'd be like,
I'm not drinking fucking anything
in this building. All right.
Okay. Uh, just, just take
the fucking script, you know,
it's some big fucking place
cause they got all that money.
Be Echo and take the fucking scratch.
Greg, you know something like, Dad,
look at that.
I gave you a fucking idea from will be,
I told you who to sell it to. Oh
Shit. Call it into the podcast.
A Paul Versey, you're on the Monday
morning podcast. I got you on speaker.
It's Thursday. Was it Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday. Monday morning.
Podcast, podcast listeners.
And yet guess what Paula,
just checking in on you. Oh Nice.
Nice. How's it going up there?
It's going great, Paul. I
got to talk to coach k today.
I do. I says, fucking nuts. So did you,
did he say anything about
that loss last night?
Uh, I asked him really quickly,
I said, what's it like as a coach
to lose a game on a last second
bank in three point shot,
like fucking 10 feet behind the arc.
I go, does that kill you as a coach?
And he said, no. He said, no.
You know what kills me is having six
fast breaks in the first half and not,
not getting any points on those.
And it's a classic.
Afterwards I thought about
it. It's just like, yeah,
he doesn't sweat the
stuff he can't control,
but it's stuff that you can control that
you should follow through on so that
the Eagle people, there's a little
teaser if you want to listen tonight. Oh,
an ex Sirius XM channel 84 at 6:00 PM.
That's fucking awesome. Jelly. She
didn't ask us something stupid.
I would have asked him something stupid.
I would've been like,
what was it like coaching, like acting
like the kids are bigger than him.
I was like, what? You like
coaching Christian later? Uh,
that's so cool.
Was He cool though?
Yeah. No, he didn't talk.
He was totally cool.
I have an idea of if I ever
get him on the podcast,
I know how I'm going to interview him,
but that, that I'm not going to give away.
I'm,
I'll tell you afterwards.
I got a great idea on how to interview
him because I figured he's been asked the
same thousand basketball questions
a million times over and I met,
my goal would be to do an interview
and try to see, you know, just
ask you to know it. Yeah, I
know you're going to be like us.
So what do you think of cars?
You start making it right.
It'd be a little more involved in that.
I wouldn't have them know.
What do you think? A car
is he going? I don't know.
I take one of the fucking venue.
You idiot. I drive white. Yeah.
I drive one at drive one all
the time. Hey Dude, I got to a,
I gotta I gotta call you right back
because I need to wrap this podcast up and
then I got to go, uh, be daddy
daycare. All right. Hey Paul.
That's exactly what I'm going to do. Okay.
It's a pleasure. Always a pleasure, Paul.
Especially since we're across the country,
Bill. Oh, you know, God bless you.
God bless you and everything
that is that you do. I'll see.
Um, anyways, so there you
go. Hey, look at that.
The first fucking call and
see I had the technology,
everybody tries to get these fucking
DSL lines of whatever the fuck they are.
UPS Shit.
Oh,
you do is you just put your iPhone on
speaker and you hold it up to the mic.
I think it gives it more of
a quality sound. You know,
all these fucking shows. They try to make
it sound like the person's in the room.
They're not in the room. They're calling
me on a cell phone. A God damn it.
That's what it's going to sound like. Bunk
call, call, call, call. Um, all right.
So there you go.
Somebody fucking right.
Then somebody write that movie and go
make a bunch of, go make a bunch of money.
Go loiter around an airport Cli. You
can fucking do that. Um, all right,
I think that's it right? Oh, so
this is what I learned the second,
third, third time I was on stage.
It's The New York comedy club.
I forgot to tell you. I'm fucking
doing my set and now it's going great.
I'm having a great set. By
the way, I didn't have a
good senate, the comic strip,
and of course the recorded in shut off.
I'm having a great fucking Senate in New
York and I looked down and Paul verse,
he's calling me, I'm like, oh, what the
fuck? Then I go, wait a minute. I go,
does the fucking recorder shut off?
If somebody calls millennials,
can you help me out? And they
were all like, yes, it shuts off.
And I go, does it come back on after
the call? And somebody said, yes.
Well guess what? It doesn't. It shuts
off. So to all you comedians out there,
if you take an ascent, if
you feel in it, you know,
you might want to reach over and fucking
put it in airplane mode in case your
mother calls, you know? Then you
got to give a shit. You know?
Thanks a lot Ma. You ruined my
new Dick. Joke. Um, all right,
that's the podcast for this
week. Um, not the podcast.
Just me checking in on you. Enjoy the
music. Now you've got another half hour.
Is Shit coming your way?
That's a, I dunno. It's, it's,
it's some greatest hits stuff
from a podcast, from a, I
don't know, a time gone by.
So when I say, and here's my
youtube channel, by the way. Um,
let's see here.
It's youtube.com/user/monday
morning podcast.
And guess what?
I'm going to start making fucking videos
and I'm going to upload it. I finally,
you know,
I never videotaped the fucking podcast.
I'm going to start making videos,
putting it up there,
starting when I go to Phoenix,
I'm going to start doing the
tours of the cities again. Um,
I got some other ideas of
some shit that I can do, um,
to add to the channel and finally try and
build that stuff up. Um, so that's it.
Once again, thank you to everybody who
did the Patrice benefit. Rich Foss,
Dan Soder, Keith Robinson, Pete Davidson,
Jim Norton, David Towl, Leslie Jones,
and Maureen Taren for putting the
whole fucking thing together. And uh,
thank you to everybody who came out.
We will do it again next year and I
think I already know who I'm going to
reach out to to try to get on the
show. That's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's up man?
It's the Monday morning podcast and
I'm going to be multitasking this week.
How right in fuck it.
Heating up some pizza and that's
what I'm having for breakfast.
I know he's supposed to have it
cold like those douchebags on ESPN.
Um,
but I'm not gonna actually in our area
ball oatmeal and now I'm fucking hungry
so I'm going to have some teacher.
Isn't that interesting?
If it like that website that you guys
are all going on a fucking a kitty
fuck.com. What can they do? That
thing where you, where you, uh,
celebrities go on there and they,
uh, what the hell they do. You know,
they type in a, you know, 1:48
PM just tied my left sneaker.
Is that, what the fuck are they giving
ends with a t how many shut me a, uh,
an email the other day about
that type of shit. You know,
seeing if I wanted to
join their, uh, their,
their website about whatever
that stuff is, you know,
it wouldn't really help if I actually had
the name of the website, which I don't,
of course, which I don't. Um, but anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Does that make any sense?
Does it ever make any sense? You
know, a lot about this podcast is,
it's fucking free,
so you can never complain about it.
Although people don't people
to bitch about the podcast and,
uh, people take it seriously
sometimes. It's amazing.
I'll do like 50 minutes a shit say,
and some of the most ignorant stuff
you're probably gonna hear all day,
if not the whole week.
You know,
if you hang out with really smart
people and people, they send me emails,
like really taking me,
I've got a lot of like
condescending emails this week. Uh,
that were really just,
I dunno,
people haven't bummed or I guess I'm
really coming off like a moron, you know,
which I openly admit that I
am. And also that, you know,
I'm just fucking joking around.
Some people, they, they, they,
they take it real seriously. I'm really
trying to fucking scroll down to this.
I actually have, you know, which, uh,
actually because of it
has made me create a, a,
a new part of the podcast. You know, at
this point, if you're new to my podcast,
what I do is I, uh, people
send me questions every week.
I try to answer them to the best of
my ability. We have the overrated,
underrated lists, people's lists of
things in life. Either of, I dunno,
entertainers or ra can openers,
whatever the fuck you want.
Anything that you think is overrated,
underrated, and a, I got an movie reviews.
That's something else. Then we got
something else. Here's the new thing.
Douche bag of the week.
All right.
This guy sent me a,
uh, an email last week.
I was talking about nature out here and
the seasons and the fires and all that
type of shit. Just bullshitting, just
trying to fill up 50 minutes, you know,
trying to help somebody out,
sitting in a cubicle or some
fucking job that they don't want,
that they're on their way out.
And this fucking asshole decides to
take me seriously. Right. I says,
what are your rights deer farmer bill
listening to you talk about nature soil in
Los Angeles.
Los Angeles is seasonal fires made me
put your intelligence on the overrated
list.
Fires don't just happen.
Are you banking your whole argument on
the theory of spontaneous combustion?
Some Douche flicks a lit cigarette
out the window and there you go. Yeah,
the trees and the foliage gets brown and
dry out, but they don't just explode.
Do you actually think we
should just let the fire burn?
Can you believe all this fucking guy?
Like I think trees just explode.
Like I really think that they should
just let the fucking hills burn and have
people's houses burned down and that
the, you know, they're rich people.
So who gives a fuck?
I mean there's a guy have any
sort of concept that in comedy,
if you just say something that's really
fucking ridiculous and over the top,
the shock of it.
What the very least bring a smile to
somebody's face unless you take it fucking
seriously. Jesus Christ. That's
one of my favorite lines ever.
Fires don't just happen.
Really?
I just thought they just happened.
Trees don't just spontaneously combust.
You know what a con,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh look at my pizza done all that
was fucking quick. You know what?
I didn't stick it in the microwave.
I don't like the microwave because it's
something Keith Richards set a fucking
funny as that. One time I read a quote
where Keith Richards says, I don't use,
I don't use cell phones cause you,
you know you might as well stick your
head in a microphone, a microwave.
And that kind of killed two
pieces of technology for me.
But I need my cell phone
so I still use that.
So I try not to use the fucking microwave.
When you think about it,
there's something just not right about it,
you know?
So I'm using the old thing. I used the
fire in the stove that just happened.
You know, it just so happened that when I
put my pizza in there, that might stove,
you know,
spontaneously combusted
Jesus fucking Christ people when
you listen to these podcasts, no,
that I don't read and know that when I
really say something stupid that I'm just
joking.
Just fucking around.
You don't need to waste 10 minutes of
your day trying to show me how fucking
intelligent you are about how you
understand how fires are started.
I like how you went with the hacky
lit cigarette out the window. Oh,
maybe he's just making fun of
my intelligence there. No wait.
He thought I thought things spontaneously
combust. I don't fucking know.
But he gets douche bag of
the week. Okay. All right.
I don't mind when I do standup on TV.
If somebody you know,
sends me an email and says,
you know,
I just thought your comments about
rescue dogs, but completely ridiculous.
I wish abortion was retroactive.
You know,
just kind of shut up emails I've gotten.
I understand that because
those people are fans of mine.
They don't know what it is that I do,
but I figure if it listened to my podcast,
you realize, did I say a lot
of over the top stupid shit?
And I don't mean any of it.
All right?
So you don't really need to fucking
send me emails. Just, you know,
what I'm really trying to do is save your
time. I'm actually thinking about you.
Look at me. Be in the modern.
Uh Huh. Just like Mother Teresa
was actually talking to this comedian
yesterday. This Guy Doug Davidoff.
He's fucking hilarious. If you
ever get a chance to see him. Uh,
he was talking to some how would keep
came around and we'd talking about Mother
Teresa and he said to me
that evidently one at a time,
she was talking about poverty in the
world and she said something to the effect
of, uh, the worst poverty she's
ever seen was, I think in India.
And the second worst was actually right
here in America and was basically saying
that,
um,
the poverty of the spirit
in America is staggering.
And you know, which really made
me wish she was still alive.
So I could just slap that
fucking none head. Right.
But none hat right off her fucking head.
I am so sick of fucking
people trashing America,
you know, acting like where they
live is this fucking great place.
Okay. Now I haven't hit all
the countries. All right?
But I've been to Australia, I've been
to Canada. This is pathetic. I've,
I went to Ireland. They're the
same fucking people. They, they,
they haven't figured out what life is
all about. I went into fucking Ireland.
It's a Wednesday night in the pub is
packed with fucking people. Okay. Those,
that's people's dads in there who should
be at home tossing a machete lately or
whatever the fuck they supposed to do
as a dad over there and then not fucking
there. So if they really understood,
you know, what makes you happy in life?
Oh my God.
Did my computer just fucking crash?
Oh fuck.
This is the day that I've been dreading.
This is the day that I, I kept putting
off, I'll buy a laptop next month.
I buy one next month. Don't
do this to me, baby. Come on.
We've been through too much. Wow. To
anybody out there go to computers.
My screen just went,
I'd sort of a blue black and
all the typing is now in yellow.
I can still read it. Oh, what do I
do? I hold the power button down.
We try to reboot it.
Fucking is getting cold.
This is just a cluster fuck whatever. I
don't, I don't need the fucking questions.
I'll just keep going.
You know what I mean?
Because sometimes in life that's what you
want me to get back to mother Theresa.
You know what I to fucking candy.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
And I know that sac religious
to say that shit, but you know,
she did too much shit when everyone
else was looking. You know what I mean?
That's why I never liked about her
say when don't they have that saying in
the Bible there's another book I never
read. I tried to, it's
just fucking, you know,
it's like update the language already,
you know?
And these set it to thou,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about. I just, you just really,
I'm sick of fucking people
acting like people in Canada are happier
than people in America or England.
Those miserable motherfuckers.
They can't even go to a soccer
game without killing each other.
Fucking Mother Teresa and she just,
you know,
did you sue big live spiritually?
Jesus Christ? I'd just like to take a
fucking pie and throw right in her face.
I wish I was the one to interviewing
her when she said, that's right.
You know what might you go fucking
hang out with a leper so we can see how
fucking great you are.
Fucking
what a downer.
You mentioned she showed up at your
party and just sitting there looking at
everybody just judging everyone
how fucking holy she is.
I wonder where she ended up
in the afterlife. You know,
just harder sell out or what a great
fucking person she was. I gotta tell you,
man, I don't buy it. I
don't fucking buy it.
Everybody's got something.
All right.
Hanging out with lepers and all
sudden you can fucking trash America.
You can jump on that Fucking Bandwagon,
Huh?
Why don't you go make
somebody some cookies.
Do what old women are supposed
to be doing. All right?
They're making cookies with bill,
with his grandma's hands playing in
the background. Okay, and until then,
shut in your face. This is the
way I like to do on my podcast.
I like to trash dead saints.
Is she a sanctuary?
She'll become a saint.
That's what the fuck she was trying to do.
You know what it really was?
She was a psycho who couldn't fucking,
she couldn't sustain a relationship.
That's what it was.
And she basically, you
know, just being famous,
which is what most Americans want,
wasn't enough for her.
She wanted to be fucking world famous. So
she traveled all around the world. Ooh,
look at me. Look at me. Oh, there's
some kids stuck in a mud puddle.
I'm pulling them out. I don't even
care if my none gown gets dirty.
That's how fucking holy I am.
Wait, did you run out of tape?
Did you run a tape and the camera?
Let me,
let me pause and wait for you to film
that. Put the kid back in the puddle
spiritually fucking bankrupt.
You know? First of all,
I don't need you to fucking
tell me that Mother Teresa.
I know how fucked in the head I am.
Okay.
Sitting there racking like you're tapped
into some sort of higher fucking power.
He got a lot of fucking balls,
a lot of fucking balls.
All right. Now that I'm down
to the crust on my pizza,
let me see, um, see if I can
reboot this fucking thing.
You know what sucks? Is there so many
fucking great questions this week?
So many great fucking emails while
this thing is not even responding,
this is just flat lining.
You fucking cunt. Don't do this
to me. Don't do this to me.
Higher cubs,
it's coming back up.
I know there's a lot of religious people
listening to this shit going while you
just trashed mother Theresa. The
fuck was that. Okay? Oh, here we go.
See that now by the trees were so
fucking holy. The way I just trashed,
or Mike,
my computer went to reboot it
or maybe she's just be in
the moderate again. She's up
in heaven. She's going, no,
it's okay. It's okay.
Let us computer work.
I don't need,
I don't need you to fucking help Terry.
All right. I know I'm eating.
This is fucking really rude,
but you know I have to
carb up before I do.
These podcasts are so fucking
long at this point. Um,
all right, whatever. Oh,
here's one that someone actually
sent me that I remember. You know,
you know every week when I go on and on
about how you should shop at mom and pop
store, just go blow out this great fucking
point when she's like, you know what?
I've tried to go into those mom and pop
places and a lot of times I, you know,
I can,
I can't even do this.
I'm not going to paraphrase it because
it's such a fucking great slam on what
the hell. I said, I don't want to row.
I don't want to ruin it. All right?
What can I talk to you guys about is I
wait for my fucking ancient computer to
boot up. Oh, here we go. Oh,
this is getting exciting.
Mac Os 10 that's my operating system.
You're still using that man. I
had it. And like the fourth grade,
you're still a loser. All
right. What do think about that?
What are you fucking base
your entire existence on your
fucking operating system?
You don't even have a camera on
your computer now. I don't. Yeah,
you jerk off on the Internet. Okay.
And someone in the Pentagon watched it.
So now you can never be president.
What do you think about that?
Cause they have that clip and
if you do become president,
you got to do everything that they say.
Oh,
we're going gonna take
out a fucking video. Uh,
you snapping at at 23 years of age.
All right,
come on. I really, you know,
I don't know how long I can sustain
this false anger as I wait for the shit.
Have I seen any good movies? Oh,
it was in Ogden, Utah, this, uh,
this weekend and I want to thank
everybody who came out to wife,
guys and Ogden, Utah. Um,
I had a great time and it was
one of the most beautiful,
a beautiful cities I've ever been
to in my life. Just unbelief.
I got up in the morning to go down and
go do the radio and I'm literally driving
down the highway on the entire left hand
side as I guess the rocky mountains,
but they're like, they're like right
there and the sun is just coming up.
It's on the other side of the mountain.
So there's this orange glow
outlining the top of the mountains,
which have snow on them.
And then below at the foot
of the mountains is the
city with the lights of the
city.
I look like a fucking postcard was unreal.
Um, you know, see that.
I appreciated that.
Mother. Teresa, how are
you going to criticize that
you shouldn't have to about hubs in
light of this city. That city is humans.
It's dirty. It should just talked about
nature. Is that what she sounded like?
Did she ever even talk or did you sit
there looking sad and judging the fucking
media who were filming her?
She laid next to somebody with Lupus.
Um, all right, here we
go. Podcast questions.
I think I've trashed Mother Teresa Long
enough. I'm glad I did that. You know,
I think it was long overdue.
Okay. Um, all right.
Eventually I'll get to that.
Ladies when move. You know what?
Why don't I just do the fucking questions
here. All right. Oh, you know what?
Here's one for you. I was fucking coming
out of the airport in Ogden, Utah,
which is brutal this time
a year, by the way. Okay.
And I want to show you guys that I,
that I am not afraid of technology,
which people start start,
I've really started to suggest because
I'm so against those automated machines
at the, uh, at the supermarkets. But, um,
I don't mind him at the airport. I'm
not going to lie to you. I really don't.
Especially when you're in ski season
and Ogun fucking Utah and everybody in
front of you is standing in with their
fucking skis and an overnight bag.
So, you know, when I saw
him when I was there,
as I take another bite of
pizza rudely, hey, you know,
why don't you go pay for a podcast?
All right? When you think about that,
go pay for a fucking podcast.
I'm sure the host won't be eating.
Don't get indignant with me.
All right.
I'm fucking hang up on you right now.
I'll leave you alone in your cubicle
then what are you gonna do? Huh?
That's right. Back to the
spreadsheet, isn't it?
All right then you think
about that anyways, sorry.
Just had to give a shit at
that. Finish that bite. Um,
so I'm going through the airport in
Ogden, Utah, big long fucking line.
All these push. Why I cannot even
begin to tell you how fucking white
Utah is. It's, it's unreal. Like I was,
you know, here like my black friends with,
you know, telling Shit, you know, a
couple of times had gone, you know,
a few of them going back to APP. You
know what? They've never said that.
And I'm actually thinking of a
Richard Pryor bit if I do that.
Your Dad was one of a friend of mine.
Oh wait a minute with someone famous
who said that Richard Pryor did that bit
about like, you know,
going back to Africa,
how all of a sudden was all black people
and it was beautiful and all this type
of stuff. Like, you know, I
was always, I don't want that
thinks like, you know what,
if you're white goatee, Utah,
you'll get that experience.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's just, it's, it's awesome.
It's just fucking wall
wall. Yt it just, you know,
and you feel real safe.
And then you realize half of them
are named Luke and mark and John,
all those biblical names. And then you're
like, okay, I'm out of here. You know,
when you guys get 10% of your income
to the Mormon church, you know,
I ask those people like, who's the most
famous Mormon who is the most, you know,
the top Mormon out there?
And somebody yelled out to Steve Young,
I thought that was fucking hilarious
and entire relationship, relationship,
entire religion.
You know what I mean?
You'd think that they would
pick somebody who, I dunno,
did the Mother Teresa Shit and
when they'd pick the fucking, uh,
the stand in for Joe Montana
got fucking,
it annoys me.
I don't like Steve Young either.
He went on and on about the Patriots
fucking cheating. I love that.
I think they keep quiet, you know,
people question the Patriots.
Super Bowl victories because
of that video tape thing,
which I totally understand, but nobody's
questioning the New York Yankees there.
Last two fucking world series victory.
You know when like three guys were on
fucking roids remember Roger Clemens?
How fucking roided up with that guy?
He threw a ball through.
Mike Piazza is bat,
the fucking bat end of it comes
flying out. I'm like 80 miles an hour.
He catches it bare handed and then throws
it and he was like the hulk and people
are, he's amped up for the game. He
was roided out of his fucking tree
telling you one of these days I'm
going to climb up on New York,
the Yankee Stadium.
I'm going to fucking erase those last
two championships and then they'll only
have 24 it'd be still 200 and ahead
of the red sox. All right, sorry,
I'm just killing time here.
All right. Uh, oh. Anyway,
so I'm going to the fucking
airport and is what they ended up.
So there's this big long line of a bunch
of Lawrence Welk looking white people.
Everybody looks like they play like
the trombone or some shit. Right? Um,
and uh,
so they got this thing on the side.
If you want to bypass this is the new
thing that they have in airports. Okay.
If you want to bypass the long
lines and security, you know,
if you're not flying first class,
if you just some regular Joe who can't
afford a first class fucking ticket and
you don't want to stand in line, they
got this great new piece of technology.
We're,
all you gotta do is just get fingerprinted
and have your retina scan and you can
go right by everybody.
You know what I love about that and see
this one lady in front of me is like,
wow, is that how that God, if
that how I've found, that's great.
That's great. You fucking
idiot. Yeah, that's great. Yeah.
And then everybody does it,
right?
And then you standing in the fucking
line again and what's it going to be?
How it's going to be a little bit
quicker and now they have your fucking
fingerprint, the fingerprinted,
like you committed a felon,
whatever. What are you going
to do or people be able to,
there's going to give into it and then
I'll be the last guy not to give into it
and then you know what? I'll be standing
and the old school life by myself,
you know, then I'll be going quicker.
No, it's not going to work out.
It's kind of like the easy pass.
Everybody eventually got the
fucking easy pass and then,
and then like nine out of 10
lines and now all easy pass.
And now I'm fucking sitting there with
like nine guys and people don't get your
fucking fingerprints taken to get on
a God damn plane and get your fucking
retina scan.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ. Well, if
you're not doing anything wrong,
I don't understand what the problem is.
I'll see you in the FEMA camp.
All right, question bill. Hey Bill.
How difficult was it to tell people you
wanted to become a comedian when you
first started? Um, what
were some of the reactions?
For me it was like
telling them you want it,
you want it to be a superhero
was at the same for you.
I got to tell you something.
I did not even a,
I never told anybody anybody that
I was going to be a comedian. Um,
I didn't tell anybody I was even doing
it and I didn't let anybody even come and
see me until I've been doing
it for well over a year.
Like it's always amazed me,
the people who have the fucking balls
the first time they go on stage to do
stand up setting yourself up for quite
possibly one of the most humiliating
things that could ever happen to you
other than a fucking prison rape,
which is basically to stand in front
of a bunch of people and get booed off
stage like their first time on stage.
Like they would bring the entire office
that the people that they work with to
come down and see him. It's like how you,
you, you can't see the possibilities.
It's like dude,
they didn't ever think like what if I
fucking bomb and then I have to go back to
work on Monday and look and no
one's going to look me in the eye.
You actually going to ruin all their
weekends cause they're going to be sitting
there worrying what the fuck they're
going to say to you on Monday when they
come in. But to answer your
question, um, yeah, it's,
it's a very, uh, it's very hard
thing to do in a weird way. You know,
it's sort of like a sort of like coming
out telling people you're gay I guess
can be fucking sense.
I'm just know you just kind of like,
how am I going to tell my
parents that, uh, you know,
all that money was spent on college
education and now I'm going to go on stage
and talk about my Dick. Um, yeah,
it was very difficult, but I was, my
parents were unbelievably supportive.
Thank God. And then maybe I
think I in within the first year,
I told one of my close friends that
I was doing it and I, but I did not,
I didn't tell anybody else
because I knew what they were.
You going to come out and see,
you know, you're not doing that.
You're not doing that because
I bomb horrifically, you know,
one out of every four times at this
point and I that's just too high a ratio.
Some, yeah, I waited a good year. Um,
and even then it was just
a couple of people shell.
Oh, is that a good bite of pizza?
Which is really annoying. I'm sorry,
I went with the quattro for Romaji
so I can have a,
that'd be great if I had a fucking heart
attack right there in the middle of
this podcast,
would you guys even know who to call?
Would you help me out?
You probably wouldn't.
You'd probably save it and trying to put
it on your website to be the first one.
Comedian dies during free podcast.
While it'll be hilarious and I die in
the first person I see his mother Teresa,
just looking at me. Um, all
right, Bill, next question. Um,
this is such a great question.
So is my ex girlfriend,
the only con that assumes a breakup is
an opportunity to make a fucking pen pal.
She writes once a month to let me know
what's going on and ask how I'm doing.
It's garbage.
Who told this bitch that small talk
via email starts when the fucking ends.
The only note I want to see from
this Twat is a suicide note.
Ah, God damn it. That fucking email
me made me laugh when I read that.
Read it late last night. You
guys, I'm telling you everything,
everybody stepping up their game there,
the questions are getting better.
You guys are learning how to write.
It'll be out of a fucking job here. Um,
I'll dude, you don't have
to answer the emails. Um,
you sound like you're
almost as angry as I am.
So I'm going to try to go easy here
and talk you off the ledge. Um,
it's not a bad thing. I
mean it, that's kind of,
seems like you had a good breakup and
she still wants to be friends with Dan.
If you can kind of still
be friends with them. Um,
and you always got to watch
out with women. Now you go,
he's got to watch out because you know,
she might just be staying in contact
with you so she can, you know,
as she's asking how you're doing subtly,
you know,
push those buttons in your head that she
still remembers the combination too and
you know,
subtly let you know how good her life is
going with the airline pilot that she's
fucking now dating or something.
You got to watch out for that shit.
But if she's just being cool,
she sounds like a cool person who maybe
every once in a while you could, uh,
you know, maybe get a fucking hand
job out of. All right, underrated. Um,
van Halen is running with the
devil. This is the same guy. Uh,
he says underrated van Halen running
with the devil. When I get my born again,
brothers answering machine,
I always screamed,
Jesus fucking Christ Ansia Goddamn phone.
Then I sing running with the
devil and laugh. Ah, Jesus.
You know,
there's not enough people like this guy
in the world that's really fucking funny
and I can't even read is overrated
because he's trashing a comedian.
I don't do that on here, but it
was, it's fucking hilarious. Um,
see what I did there.
I probably shouldn't even said that.
Now look and read it and I go
fuck yourself. I'm not doing that.
Might get involved in that biggie.
Tupac Shit. All right. Uh, Bill,
what's your best relationship? What,
what was your best relationship?
What was your worst? Jesus Christ.
It wasn't my best relationship.
Um,
probably the one I'm in now
because we can have knock down,
drag out fights and then the end
will end up laughing occasionally.
I would say that is the best
one because when you're younger,
you don't know how to be in a fucking
relationship. You know what I'm saying?
He just sit there and, yeah,
yeah. You know, for me anyways,
you let the other person walk all
over you and in your head you're like,
I don't want to fucking do
that. But then you're like, oh,
keep it happy or it won't fuck me.
And then you just continue to lose ground.
And, uh, I had met,
I had an argument the other day that
it should have been recorded and
transcribed and put into every
men's magazine out there.
It was just one of those
fucking arguments. You know,
where your girlfriend is in a
bad fucking mood and or whatever,
thinks you did some shit and she's not
thinking about the situation you're in.
So she starts giving you shit.
And you know,
for the first few minutes I took it like,
what do I do?
Typical Moron guy before
I finally flipped out,
I seem distant. Yeah. I'm in the
middle of fucking nowhere. I mean,
you've talked upon for a fucking
God damn rednecks out here. Okay.
I got up at eight in the fucking morning
driving along these fucking mountains.
Yeah, I'm a little distance.
Okay. Fuck is wrong with you.
The fuck is wrong with you. Get
leave me alone. Leave me alone.
You're being a jerk.
I'm watching the bill Maher show talk
to you tomorrow and hung up on it.
That was it. Was it? Um,
you know what?
I actually started to tell that argument.
I just sort of fucking bailed on it
cause that's a little too personal. Um,
all right.
Well I recently moved from Michigan
to go to Grad school at Ucla.
I like to see me. This is another
fucking quite one. Here we go. Um,
I recently moved from Michigan
to go to Grad school at Ucla.
I haven't met one person
that is worth my time in la.
Everyone is so fucking fake and thinks
that I give a shit about how many
calories they've eaten this week.
I can't enjoy myself in the nice
weather cause I carry these wonderful
Midwestern man boobs around with me
while even the people that work at
Mcdonald's have their shirts
off showing off their abs.
Are there any cool places to go around La?
This is such a great email because this
is what it feels like when you first
move out to la.
Okay?
You go with the usual criticism. Oh
my God, everybody's still plastic.
Everybody's so fight.
Everybody's so fake.
But the reality is if you really
read between the fucking lines,
I didn't think you have to with this
email is when you move out here,
you realize everybody isn't,
you know, not everybody,
but there's a lot of people who are in
great fucking shape and you know you're
going to be a fat fuck in Michigan and
not even realize it. You know what I mean?
Cause he just didn't hurt you.
Just a bunch of buffaloes walking
across the plane. You don't know.
Everybody thinks and
then you get out there,
you know you get so fucking freaked
when you first get that to you actually
invent shit. That didn't happen. You know,
everyone thinks I give a shit about how
many calories they've eaten this week.
I love that line because
obviously no one came up and said,
do you know I've had only
1200 calories this week.
It's just you start creating
shit in your head, you know,
and like the people in Mcdonald's are
in such good shape that, you know,
to make the point you actually have to
act like they took their shirts off.
You know, which I know, obviously
you're exaggerating for effect,
unlike that Douche bag who sent me the
fucking thing about the fires out here.
Um, relax dude. What's going to happen
is you're going to join a gym, okay?
You're going to let go of that. You know,
it's not minus 3000 degrees out. So,
um,
actually somehow not living a full life.
Relax. You join a gym,
you get in better shape,
you learn about nutrition and all of
a sudden you start feeling better.
And then one day it's January and
it's fucking 70 degrees out. And you,
when your buddies calls from
fucking back east and he disliked,
you want to be like, dude, you know,
you don't have to live like that.
You really don't. So there's plenty
of cool places to go around Hollywood.
Now if you want to,
you don't go. You know,
if you're in Hollywood on fucking sunset,
you might as well be in Times
Square in New York City. So, uh,
there's plenty of cool places to go
to out in la. A lot of outdoor stuff.
You could literally take up surfing
the fucking beaches. This shit.
They got all these mountains around
here where you can go hiking.
You got all that outdoor stuff, we'll,
we'll just melt away those man boobs.
Not to mention they got a bunch
of hot broads out here. Yeah,
there are a little plastic and fake down,
but go down to like Hermosa beach.
Doesn't that just gorgeous.
And they're not trying to be an actress
and they got fucking tell me, just,
just go to go down there.
Okay.
Do you get out of the usual fucking
Moron riff Raff when you go down there on
the beach?
That definitely the pit bull guys and the,
the Douche bags with their motorcycles
and stuff. But believe me, you know,
I've seen Detroit, so you really
shouldn't be bitching. Um,
I guess you wanted literally
a list of cool places. Um,
I don't know if you've
noticed the way I've dressed,
I'm not exactly a trendsetter. Um, and
I know where there's some cool bars,
but I'm not going to say them
over my podcast because, um,
I don't need 11 of my 14
listeners showing up ruining me,
drowning my sorrows in my whiskey.
Okay. All right, next one. Bill.
Love the podcast. Love you. Stand up.
I've decided to follow your lead
in the self checkout crusade.
I no longer use them anymore because you
said because what you said makes sense
to me. Jesus. Thank God I
only got to some person.
I'd like to offer you a deal though.
Since I've given up self
checkout lanes at grocery stores,
all I ask is that you look
deeper into paying bills online.
I've done it for years with no problems.
I love it.
I understand your concerns about it,
so that's why I merely look.
I say merely look into
what into it with your bag.
It's okay to be skeptical of technology,
but don't be skeptical because it's
technology. Have a great day. All right,
well that was my point
earlier. I'm not, you know,
I'm not a hundred percent
against technology. Obviously.
I'm a big fan of penicillin
loving the airplane.
I'm not. I'm just like,
my thing is I don't like
technology where you know,
they're acting like it's making it
easier and what they're really doing is
getting a ridiculous amount of personal
information on me that they can then use
for God knows what,
like fingerprinting me and scanning my
retina at the fucking airport so I can
get on a Goddamn plane,
I think goes above and beyond.
It goes above and beyond and I know
it can easily be explained away by the
fucking tour to emails and
I'm going to get, you know,
and they're all going to be of the same
ilk of trusting the psychopaths at the
top of the heap. And I just don't,
that's it. And as far as, uh,
you know, paying your
bills online, I mean,
the only safety you have is that you,
that a bunch of people do it and you're,
you're stuck and know you're in
the middle of the herd, you know.
But if you get to the outside of the hurt
and you have that little fucking deer
limping or that baby deer, okay, these,
you know, I don't know. You can
do it. Do it if you want to do it.
I'm just saying I don't fucking trust it.
I'm not going to put my
bank account numbers on.
I was mainly talking about banking.
I wasn't necessarily talking about
paying bills, but even that shit,
I just don't like doing it. You know?
I don't like doing it. You can do it.
Go for it. It's all for you. I don't
know. I like the old school, you know,
I take out my checkbook. Nobody sees my
account numbers. I put it in an envelope,
some guy at the post office fucking
when no one's looking at opens it up,
then he looks at it. Then he's
got to do a whole bunch, you know?
You know what I'm saying?
All I got to worry about,
it's the people at the post
office. I, you know something,
I actually did a little research on this
after buddy of mine who was a lawyer
and I asked him, what is the number one
way people get their identity stolen?
And he said, uh, people
stealing your mail.
And uh, what did he move on?
Why did he put it? Miss Miss,
miss guided trust or something like
that. Basically you try, you know,
you're dating some chick and
she fucking, you know, you know,
you think that she's enjoying you as
much as you're enjoying her and she's
really just say, oh, whatever. You
know what I mean? Somebody at work,
you leave your purse there or your wallet.
We know what misguided trust means.
You don't need to explain it.
I am sorry. So I, I, you know,
I get worried about that type
of stuff. And I also, you know,
the thing about doing banking online is
I realized that every account is insured
up to 100 grand. And I've heard rumors
that they're going to bump it up.
Somebody sent me an email that they're
going to push it up to two 50. But, uh,
I don't know about you guys,
but the last five years looking at how
insurance companies handle claims and
bankers, those are like two of the
most corrupt fucking people out there.
Insurance companies and bankers.
And I'm not putting my, uh,
I'm not putting my faith in them.
You know,
I don't understand why people are
still doing that. Like I said before,
I don't know. I'm a paranoid psychopaths
and sometimes it hurts me in life,
but a lot of times it helps me and
I think this is going to help me.
I'm not fucking banking online.
You guys can do what you want to pay
your bills online. You can do it.
I'm not doing that either. And
uh, I'm not getting my fucking,
I'm not getting fingerprinted and my
retina scan to get on a fucking airplane.
I'm not doing that either.
And I'm not going to the grocery store
scan in my own fucking food and bagging
my own groceries under the guise that
it's quicker and easier. It isn't.
It's a lot easier for me to just stand
there with my hands and my fucking pocket
and have someone else do it for free.
All right.
That's all I'm saying.
So I'm sick of arguing this point.
If you want to use the automated
fucking grocery store thing,
by all means go ahead and do it. If you
want to bank online, pay your bills,
want to get your fucking retina scan,
it'd be fingerprinted. I'm not saying
don't do this shit. I'm saying,
I guess I do say don't do it, but
I think I say please don't, I,
I dunno. Whatever you want to do it,
go ahead and fucking do it. You know,
just know that I'll be sitting there
thinking that you're a moron. Okay.
And if you can handle that, then that's
a, that's a great, that's, you know,
you'll be building yourself
up spiritually. Why should
you care what I think?
All right. A long time ago I, uh, talked
about what was the sweet spot in history,
you know what I mean? Like living in this
country, like what was perfect, you know,
I'm looking at, you know, some
people who are really old, you know,
if you're in your 80s or 90s,
it's still had to live through the
fucking depression, the dust bowl,
all the wars. And I was trying to think
what, what the sweet spot was. And
I don't know, I was trying to
think, you know, maybe if you,
if you just Miss World War II,
she had flat feet,
you didn't have to go to Korea and
then you were too old to Vietnam.
I don't know. I look at a lot of it
like, uh, like a cars and sports.
So I want to be,
I would want to be alive when
sports weren't segregated,
you know, so I could see the
Lebrons and that type of shit.
But I also want to live when
the fucking cars with a shit.
And for me that's the
forties, 50s and 60s. So, uh,
I guess the, the first year
I would have to sit through,
you know,
all white people playing all sports.
But as long as I didn't know what
black people look like playing sports,
what I know that it sucked.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like when I first was a kid,
I used to listen to Mitch Miller records.
I didn't know any better.
I didn't know led Zeppelin existed.
And then I find out they stole
their first two albums. Okay.
We're going to get into that again,
built to shut the fuck up. All right,
so this is,
this person is basically weighing in
what they think is the best period. Uh,
the sweet spot where you could come
up, come of age, live a good life,
have a nice car,
and not have to deal with these scary
fucking times that we're living in right
now. Uh, hey bill,
about six months ago you
were talking about the sweet
spot in America, blah, blah,
blah, blah, because I couldn't decide
on when are you couldn't, um, you said,
well today I was watching
dazed and confused.
You know that movie
there and I think it's,
I think the sweet spot is a senior
in high school in the 1970s when the
meatball,
Mike Lowell over the green monster
sweet spot on the bat of American. Oh,
I'm read that wrong of course, because
I suck at reading. He said, I think, um,
I think it's senior in the 1970s was
the meatball Mike Lowell over the green
monster sweet spot on the
bat of American history here,
out of wars and all, all
that. But all that bullshit,
but it's before global warming,
population crisis, crystal Meth,
hyperinflation, steroids, and
George Bush share. We don't,
we wouldn't have toys like
the Internet and the Ipod,
but I'm 20 now and I'll gladly give
up all the achievements to go back.
Uh, I just fucking lost warning. It wasn't
this, I'm such a bad out loud reader.
Uh, all the achievements to go back to
the seventies rock and a mullet speeding
around in a caprice,
not giving a fuck unaware that fossil
fuels are exhaustible smoking weed out of
those Cheech and Chong Polak poorly rolled
joints back when we'd wasn't a laced
with amphetamines and h and
habit forming. Uh, well,
I mean they didn't have a gas crisis
in the early seventies, but uh, yeah,
I know what you mean. That is a great
fucking time. Yeah. Not wearing a condom.
That's another great point.
Morning after pills and penicillin.
Have a nice day. These
guys here. You guys,
you guys are all making great points
this week. It's really well written.
If I could just fucking read it.
Um,
I'd have to agree with that because then,
you know what's else is great is if
you came with New York in the 70,
if you were a senior in the 70s,
you could also pick up a muscle car at
that point, you know, be 10 years old.
He could probably get it for nothing.
You know,
because people didn't realize that
fucking all these Goddamn nerds,
we're going to come around and ruin it.
Bloody wrath restoration,
all original. It's got the original
radio. Yeah. It's $170,000.
And he had said that
you haven't seen those fucking those,
you know,
I think those are bailing want to
go to for those as a banker, right.
Dr Assumption who can afford to fucking
pay $150,000 for God their Mustang
I Omega Mike gets anymore. Um,
alright. Douche bag of the week.
I already did this. Would you like
to hear my snarky email back to him?
Why?
Yes.
I actually do believe the trees just
explode and fires only burned brown shit.
I've never heard of this cigarette lit
cigarette phenomenon that you speak of.
Could you elaborate? That's what a,
that was a tone I took with them.
God, I'm so stupid. Thank you
for putting me in my place.
It's amazing that you caught that.
I record 50 minutes of
ridiculous statements last week,
none of which were meant to be taken
seriously except for the part about the
fires.
I was by no means deliberately saying
ignorant things in order to give someone a
laugh. I truly believed every word of
the fire state of the Union address.
Thank God you let me know.
Both the serious,
serious nature and the cause of fire.
Fire's just don't happen.
I've got to commit that to memory.
I will make sure to detract my
statements next week, which I didn't.
I actually just created
Douche bag of the week,
but for all I know that person was just
trying to be sarcastic back to me and I
misread it. Maybe that's
what it was. Um, all right,
and here's some information. Um, you
know, I say a lot of shit that, you know,
evidently I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
I was just bitching about
muscle cars being overpriced.
I always talk about vintage guitars,
you know,
they have some fender strat with Johnny
Rotten snot on the fucking fret board
and it gets 50 grand now and this guy
is saying you're complaining about the
cost of finches guitar
guitars is largely unfounded.
I'm going to stop right there sir and
let you know that most of my opinions are
largely unfounded.
That should be the name
of my next next special,
largely unfounded specialize
specifically in the case of both, uh,
fender and Gibson, the two companies
you cited in your rant, um,
where the quality of the,
their production line took a huge nosedive
from the mid eighties up until the
last two years or so.
Switching to oversee workers for the bulk
of their production using cheaper wood
paint, electronics, overall
craft, craftmanship, et Cetera,
have all added to the
embarrassingly low quality.
Most instruments on the market today.
I'm definitely with you on
muscle cars being overrated,
but any Gibson or fender model made before
1978 as well worth a decent chunk of
change. Alright, great fucking
points putting me in my place.
Yeah,
it's like bid my,
my thoughts on that away
beyond largely unfounded.
I really don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about. The,
I'm just equating it to like the housing
market where if you bought a house 10
years ago,
that was a great thing to do.
But if you bought one fucking three
years ago or in an apartment like I did,
you're a fucking moron.
And when I'm saying right now is I think
once everybody is aware that how much
something is worth and that
it's going to be, you know,
worth a lot of money in the future,
I really feel like nine times out of 10
once it's exposed like you want to be
buying those guitars 2010 20 years ago
when nobody realized no one really thought
about how much they were going to be
worth. Cause then you could get them
for nothing. You know what I mean?
But now you're paying top dollar.
I mean you're paying 50 grand
for offender fucking strat.
I mean if they're going to be what,
the hundred and three year,
I mean I don't, I don't know. I
don't, I don't understand that.
And it's Kinda like houses,
right? I bought mine,
I bought an apartment at
the peak of this shift.
I bet it's not even worth two thirds
of what the fuck I paid for it.
And now it's all coming down.
That's all I'm saying.
I think that's what I'm saying.
Maybe I'm trying to warm out of it because
you told so totally fucking nailed me
to the floor on that one. All right. You
know what? I can't argue. All you guys,
at some point, I have to admit, I
don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about. I'm goddamn comedian.
I just looked at a guitar and I'm like,
yeah, it sounds good. But you know,
it's fucking, it's kind
of scuffed up, you know,
you'd think for fucking the 50 grand,
it wouldn't be so scuffy that's all
I'm saying. I'm speaking of which,
this is the last thing I'm gonna say.
And then I've got to wrap up this
podcast at 45 minutes is uh, I went to a,
I took a drive down the street the
other day and I swear to God yesterday,
Sunday out here in la and he three miles
stretch driving over to the highway.
Um,
I saw 14 open houses.
Um, I've never seen anything
like this in my fucking life.
And uh,
I don't know.
And if for some reason you can also get,
can somebody explain this to me?
Why there's all these houses for sale.
I understand why all the houses for sale,
I get that.
Okay.
But what I don't understand is why you
can also get a great deal on rent out
here.
I would think that all those people,
obviously they're leaving their
houses that would cause the rental,
the amount of rental units to go down
because people who are living in houses
that they air,
quote owned would then be now looking to
rent and then rents would be going up.
But it's the reverse out here.
So the only thing I can guess is
that people are leaving Los Angeles.
They just saying fuck it, you know,
I don't know. I don't fucking know.
Is that,
is it like that where you guys are rent
or there were a bunch of open houses?
I mean it did. It's, this guy told me, uh,
yesterday was trying to
say that they're out here.
They're giving you first he fell,
he found a place they're giving the
first month for free and you get in a
fucking iPod. And I actually
thought like, that's a great deal.
I'm going to go do that.
And I'm like, wait a minute,
it's going to cost me twice that to
fucking pack all my shit up and move.
Why don't I just go buy an
iPod and stay where I'm at?
See that I'm not always a
moron. Right. All right.
This was a really weird podcast.
I understand that. But um,
Oh,
before I,
before I a step away here from the phone
and get on with my God Damn Day, um,
I want to let you guys know
that the contest winners,
the, uh, the birds are away.
I send out the DVDs so I don't have to
worry about being called the eight wastes.
I sent two out of three of them.
One person,
I'm still waiting for you to email
me back and you know who you are.
You're the guy who drove up to me when
I was in Houston, Texas outside the bar.
Freaked me out and handed your
prostate exam manuscripts.
I still need your, uh, your address
so I can send you a DVD. All right.
And uh, and that's basically it. And
uh, what have I got going on this week,
this week? Uh, for all you
people in lots of Hong delays.
I'm going to be doing a benefit down
at the comedy store tomorrow night, uh,
Tuesday, February, uh, 24th,
I think.
I got the flyer right here on my desk
and when I got here, wait, no, wait,
it's on the 26th c then
almost hyped the wrong date.
I'm a fun way am,
and then I canceled that other gig.
I could have done the other gig.
All right.
February 26th I'm going to be at the
comedy store and it's a benefit for world
hunger. It's going to be me,
Kevin Nealon, Jeff Richards,
and a bunch of other hilarious
fucking people. Look,
I've built myself first there,
the EGOMANIAC than I am. Why?
When I say Kevin Nealon Farsi is actually
famous in his own. That great break.
Show the weeds. I just fucking
Bang my head on this. Goddamn.
I got this room and my fucking apartment
where you're supposed to have like they
had this, this, this
goddamn iron chandelier.
Alright, that's hanging from the
ceiling and I don't know what it is.
I'm about five [inaudible] 10 and this
thing hits me right in the center of my
forehead. So it's probably
hanging about five foot eight. I,
I'm supposed to have a table underneath
it and I'm supposed to sit at either end
of it, you know, I guess can you
please pass the peas? But I don't,
I use this as a fucking room.
I got my desk up against the wall
and I have this fucking light,
ah,
fucking three days.
I Bang my forehead on it and have
a forehead like superfly snuck off.
All right. Um, that really hurt. That's
one of those ones where you hit your head.
So Hi.
Hard that like only one either your eyes
starts tearing up your teeth fucking
slammed together. Okay.
Regrouping. Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for coming
out to my show out in Ogden, Utah.
I know I called you a bunch
of rednecks or whatever,
but I had a great time out there and I
will definitely be back cause it's an
awesome club.
Wise guys is a great club and the fans
were great out there and it's only a
fucking two hour flight so that
is just game set and match.
I will definitely be there and uh,
all you people who don't live
in these areas, um, let's see,
what the fuck am I going to be coming up?
Uh,
the next Gig I have is the end of March.
I'm actually taking a little bit of
time off out here as I'm working on some
stuff, some la stuff. Um,
I'm going to be at, um,
what about house it comedy in Saint Louis?
The end of March and I'm going to be at
the lake shore theater in Chicago the
first Friday in April.
I don't have my laptop
in front of me and um,
I think on April 4th, I'm going to be at
the, in New York, in the Trump marina.
It's all on my website. Okay. You're
probably looking at the dates right now.
I'm fucking everything up. Columbus,
Ohio. I have coming up in Tempe, Arizona.
Um, and I'm working on a couple other
things, possibly a San Francisco date, uh,
one night or on a Monday
night. I'm working on doing
something like that and uh,
that's the deal. But I
really, you know, blown away.
Seriously. No more box podcast.
This is serious,
Bill.
You know how Jerry Lewis can be
silly and then sometimes serious.
I'm being serious. Jerry Lewis, serious.
Jerry Lewis. That's hard to say.
Serious Jerry Lewis Right now
where I really want to thank you.
I'm really blown away by the amount of
people who come out to my shows. And, um,
I'm having some of the best shows of
my life cause I'm actually absolutely
thrilled by the amount of people
coming out to see me. And, uh,
I got a whole new hour shit for you.
So please come out to my shows.
If you can't make it, you still
got the podcast, have a good week.
Get yourself fingerprinted a retina
scan. Please don't do that shit. Okay.
Read 1984
even though it's fiction.
That's my Bible cause I'm just like,
don't, don't fucking let me, all right.
That's it.
All right,
you guys have a good week and I will
talk to you next Monday. Alright.
Take it easy.
Yeah.
Okay.